you alluded to it that there is they are
a Flight Risk the issue is this
let's be clear they're not they're not
really a Flight Risk and I'll explain
why uh but you but this is opinion so
you you have a fair argument against me
if you if you want to
so this is not because I've been saying
law so the reason why I'm from my
argument is this they went for a very
extreme measure they could have went for
house arrest they could have had put a
tag on them they wouldn't be able to
leave the country let's be clear if
there's some kind of like James Bond
type people where they can destroy the
tag they can get someone to get break
them out they can get someone to help
them leave the country
that is easily possible even in prison
but in reality these men have khalili
shown that they want to exonerate
themselves in the Romanian system
because they want to respect the country
and respect the laws and they believe
they're innocent
why couldn't they just get in a car and
drive away
because they're going to be tagged they
want to tag don't they doesn't have like
32 cars I think I tag all of them no no
they'll they'll put a tag on him so
they'll be able to monitor his movement
what do you mean by tag on him there'll
be like a a tag they'll put like a tag
on the leg isn't it so that you can
basically would know where he is at all
times oh like a um
yeah yeah yeah so yeah you have that and
then you can have security there as well
you can have many things in place to
ensure that they don't leave and to be
honest
look we know the level of wealth they've
got if they wanted they could have got
out Anytime Anyplace this is my opinion
and so and the same argument is for
prison and the same argument so how's
the rest if you believe that they can
get out in both scenarios that argument
is is essentially very similar well if
you feel like there's an international
law violation why would you go back to a
country that you feel like is violating
international law to stand trial there
I'm sorry I never understood
you're making this argument that they
want to exonerate themselves in the
Romanian system well in that case and I
guess we should just let them do the 180
days or whatever the judge feels like no
no I explained to you that what they've
done is an extreme measure so therefore
what they should be doing is they should
be getting a house arrest with the ankle
monitor to ensure that they don't leave
the house they can have security there
whatever it may be but they're going to
be tracking their movement so the only
way they do it is if they break out they
run away and then they're basically on
the run and for someone like Andrew Tay
this is my opinion who's a global Mega
star who relies on not being on the Run
who relies on his brand he would be he
would basically kill his
what if it was the case that he was
actually guilty of everything charged
would it make sense for him to run well
if he was guilty of everything charged
they could probably break him out of
prison if if he has the level of power
that that we that has been you know the
level of money like an armed militia to
go in well how is he going to break out
is he James Bond how's he going to take
his uncle Monitor and run away and again
like it's probably a lot easier than
getting a crew to break you into prison
it is probably easier but at the same
time it's not it's not easy so the whole
point is both are acceptable measures
the reality is why they're really
holding him is it's not because of
prison it's not because of anchor
because you can't keep him in a home and
that's a fair balance you can have and
keep him at home and ensure that he's on
the run and he'll have to exonerate
himself in the Romanian system I'll be
on the Run for the rest of his life in
reality the court has alluded to it the
reason they don't want him out is
because they don't want him to speak
because if he speaks publicly and says
guess what these allegations are wrong
and he's a very influential speaker they
know that that may make the Romanian
system look bad so hence why they said
we want to ensure that the respect of
the judicial system is remains in the
eyes of the people so that's actually in
my opinion why they are not letting him
out
do you agree with that or disagree no I
don't think so what do you think it is
then well I I think they have a process
that they follow I think he's probably a
Flight Risk the guy's got a lot of money
he's made a lot of statements about
breaking out of the prison system
bribing people in the prison system or
just driving away or whatever
um you know he talks about all those
passports they probably think he's like
high probability for Flight Risk the
charges are really serious so
those like you can't be used in court
right what can't be used in court didn't
you say earlier that the social media
stuff came yeah you can't convict
somebody yeah yeah you can't convince
them in court but in terms of trying to
figure out if somebody's a flight risk
or not I think the Judge himself is
alluded to the videos of like the uh
which again which again isn't that
unacceptable though as well another
point so first of all you know the
bribing point you made you said bribing
people in the prison system he's in the
prison system he couldn't bribe them so
again there's another example where he
was trying to actually saying oh I'm
gonna bribe this man bribe that man but
in reality he's in prison he's not
bribed anyway you don't know if he was
serious or not he might have tried you
have no idea well he might have tried
but it's failed doesn't it
that's an example about the prison
system but we're saying how's the rest
so you defeat it your defeat was about
the prison system not about the house
arrest the second point was in terms of
possible again another problem I kiss
you they said the the judge the the call
system they took his video like uh from
where he says I've got like so many
passports whatever it is that again for
me is unacceptable why would you take a
video where he's saying I've got so many
passports and use that as a judgment to
say that you know that he's a flight
race so he had multiple passports and
that and you've asked a very important
question and that's the question that
should be asked does he have multiple
passports contact embassies and find out
if he's got them that's what a legal
system is meant to do or have they done
that no because they've said in the core
systems that they've just used the video
on social in the remaining problems they
have no idea how many passwords he's got
according to the court documents right
now they're based a solely on social
media have they said that that they only
went on their social media or was that a
leading thing that they used on further
investigations
they said they use social media to make
that decision they did not say anything
about content contact and embassies and
find that information out so yeah that
was the basis okay well I don't know if
they've contacted uh embassies to find
out but I think that there's a lot of
information you can use to determine if
somebody's a Flight Risk that's not
going to be something that's like
completely and totally behold into like
a probable cause or um uh uh Beyond or
whatever uh Reasonable Doubt thing like
those these are decisions that judges
make um it's probably not going to be
perfect they're consistent in every case
but I agree people that have like a ton
of money that are accused of uh charges
that would be like incredibly
um with extreme gravity uh I imagine
that you're probably in most cases going
to detain people like this that would be
my guess so so my problem is this you
said that they're probably not then
probably not it's not perfect or not
consistent my argument is they should be
consistent so therefore based on
consistency see these guys should be
housed on a house arrest as opposed to
being in prison every criminal justice
system in the world is going to operate
on some level of discretion discretion
discretion see especially when when
we're talking about being consistent
when it gets to cases of this magnitude
you might only have a handful that ever
happened and all of men like in all of
humankind right like this is probably a
really unique case I don't know if
anybody's one-to-one comparison of a guy
that did online
um had women and then everything else is
going on I don't even know what
consistency would mean it's probably a
one-of-a-kind case so in terms of what
my point position is I am so if you can
answer this my point is this I my view
is this that prison is Extreme an
extreme measure you could still succeed
in your point because part of the
Romanian system is that the 180 days can
be preventative where he has house
arrest do you agree that that would be
an acceptable way of making sure that
you don't go to extremities and
basically show that you're basically
you're not out you know at least there's
some kind of balance in the system so
you
um would I trust house arrest
um I mean if it was my call I would
probably arrest a rest if somebody had
that much money that much like
opportunity I think you would probably
just arrest them because getting around
an ankle bracelet or something what does
the rest of us mean as in like detain
them somewhere not like give them an
ankle bracelet and hope they don't flee
the country somehow
so yeah so that's why we disagree we all
agree here that if Andrew but if Andrew
wanted to fool an ankle bracelet and
leave the country could he do that
um hypothetically he could do that
hypothetically he could probably break
out prison but hypothetically speak but
it would be easier though but it would
be easier for Uncle investment but but
in reality in reality he won't do that
because he won't want to be on the Run
for the rest of his life I don't know
well we don't know that though no no we
know that because if you know that
because you're assuming he's innocent
but no no no give everything he's done
no you would want to be on the Run for
the rest of his life because he might go
to jail for 30. no no because the
problem is even if you're guilty or
innocent
so if guilt is equal in Ma so if less if
he's found guilty and he's on the run or
it's almost the same because he loses
everything the only difference is that
you're in prison which obviously much
worse but my point is so for him when he
when we look at the evidence it would be
silly to go on the run it would be
ridiculous because you're basically
giving up everything yeah but he doesn't
know we don't know what he's done
neither of us do if he's actually guilty
of this and more
um then it wouldn't it would make sense
for him we don't know as a matter of
fact so you're talking about certainty
philosophical certainty but in reality
what we know is based on the evidence
you agree I think we would all agree
here Vander Tate in if he knew it now we
don't know this we don't know this okay
I don't know hypothetical if he had done
all of this he literally had a text
group called The Lover Boy recruiters
and he did all of it and he raped seven
women more than even if he did all of
that yeah and now the Romanian people
are breathing down his neck he'd
probably rather move to Russia and live
there as a as a poor person than go to
jail for you know the rest of his life I
think that's fair if he definitely did
that that would be evidence doesn't
suggest that what the evidence suggests
is that arguments weak if anybody's in
his position based on the evidence and
data that we have in front of us it
would be silly to run so therefore how's
the rest would be more sure but I'm
saying the judge doesn't know that right
no no the judge knows the evidence so
the judge knows the information the
judge doesn't know if he actually come
into the crime or not though if he
didn't commit the crime then it makes
sense that he would stay because he
would stay he would fight in the court
system he would win but if he did and
the prosecution was just you know one
inch away from uncovering something
liberal then he's probably gonna run
another makes his decision based on what
he thinks that the person thinks that he
would have done the judge makes his
decision based on the evidence that he
has in front of him and based on the
evidence he hasn't confront of him it's
very weak and So based on that one would
surmise that this person wouldn't go on
the run and therefore they would house
arrest would be an appropriate sure that
I mean that's your opinion on the
evidence I accept that this this one was
opinionated sure
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible